what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I bring on red pill
and conservative personalities to have
conversations about the culture the
media and just you know things going on
all right so today I have Dom Luker on
the channel so you are the craziest
tweeter on Twitter
you have like the wildest Twitter
threads I have ever seen oh wow they're
saying a lot
that is that's some statement that
platform is the wildest real well okay
maybe I'll get maybe it's an
over-exaggeration maybe like top top but
you're up there I'm like because you are
like the first person I see breaking
like any crazy story yeah I'll try to
just uh mainly validate what a lot of
people's concerns are yeah and initially
started coming in I came in with the
mindset just to validate a lot of the
claims that people were told was crazy
conspiracy Etc you know a lot of people
just requesting their realities and I
want to give them something type of
Midway like some type of medium to give
them sources behind their beliefs to let
them know Well maybe I'm not crazy maybe
there is some truth to these things now
some of it is just straight BS but
majority of them I'll touch on the
things that people might have heard
before but never really gotten any
sources behind it and that uh that's
basically how I got in just to give
people a lot of validation behind their
thoughts and beliefs so where are you
from originally I'm born in North
Augusta well sorry one in Columbia South
Carolina I grew up in North Augusta
North Augusta was near the Masters but
it was North Augusta South Carolina
South Augusta Georgia okay what did you
do like before Twitter before I did a
couple things I did the Army and had my
own business I was also in hip-hop those
are like the main three things I've done
fire okay and what was like your first
viral thread or tweet I I have a couple
pulled up here but what was like the
first thing that like pushed put you on
the map very first one was I got a phone
call from Senator Warren Up's campaign I
live up here in Nashville Tennessee and
they called me to vote in their 2023
election in November Tennessee resident
couldn't do it's not possible not legal
and uh they kind of try to coerce me
really try to convince me in every way
to vote for him although being a
Tennessee resident we only have a
one-party record consent State here so I
was able to record a conversation of me
and the campaigner and that got me 30
000 Twitter followers in November of
last year and I dropped my first thread
in January and that pushed me to a
hundred thousand it's been going since
January really wait so they were
basically trying to get you to vote in a
state where you weren't registered to
vote in that's correct how how could
they do that it's so they do it through
mail-in Valance a million vote they
would have me I guess signing my
information and send it off in a Mill
and it would accommodate us a vote for
Senator Warner because I had former
Georgia resident it was like well it
still sold in the system but George was
sold she was basically saying like you
know you're still in the system of
Georgia so you can still support Civil
War I'm like yep it might show an
address like the way she was doing it
she was trying to be slick with it she's
like you have an address in Georgia I
said it shows address in Georgia but I
don't have one in Georgia she said well
the system shows you have one since you
still have an address you can vote for
him it's like she intentionally ignored
me stand up physically on that address
anymore so she was really trying to
convince me to vote for them do you
think that's common I think when they're
I believe it depends on the state I do
truly believe it depends on the state
and that to take place in Atlanta my
address in Atlanta I think it's more so
common in Atlanta than necessarily
universally around the United States
what about you I'm from Chicago what do
you think of that probably happens there
too yeah yeah I mean I had uh Laura
Lightfoot there not I don't see the
people of Chicago ever really resonating
with hurt but she got in somehow so yeah
so have you always been conservative Yes
actually yep thank you sir since I was
six years old okay and what's like the
craziest um conspiracy theory that you
found to be true uh Donald Trump
president Donald Trump saving children
just the uh how much dedication he puts
against human trafficking the amount of
success that he's had against going
against human trafficking even after the
quote unquote presidency it's just at
first it made it seem like it was just a
scapegoat or just a political opinion
and uh it's much more than that
something that is extremely important
you know to president Trump and the team
and uh just at first it might have seen
just like a conspiracy that it was just
some talk online but I just found out a
lot of effects and details behind it I
will put that as number one just about
how important it might be well how I'm
just curious how do you tell the
difference because like coming into I I
I came into the red pill space and but
I've always been more more conservative
but you just hear stuff online and I I
feel like it's so hard to tell the
difference between like what's true and
what's not true so what's like the
process that you go through and that's
the age that we live in we are in fifth
dimensional Warfare uh you know War it
does change what every 10 20 years to
generation of war the fourth
generational Warfare was drone strikes
and third generational Warfare was like
missiles and things and whatnot second
generation with the planes fifth
generation of warfare which we I think
we entered about eight years ago about
eight years ago is actually War of the
Mind psychological warfare there are
more Wars taking place online Believe It
or Not than there are on a battlefield
simply because we transitioned into
fifth generational Warfare all nations
transitioned into fifth generation
Warfare and with that it goes without
saying that if there is internet that's
been weaponized you're gonna have
information overload it's intentional
for people to be confused to question
their beliefs and question what they
read my reviewing process is to get a
source that I want to research on and
find out multiple different opinions
from around the world not just verify
different message boards America isn't
the only one with Reddit and quora every
other country has like a message board
hear what the people are saying I'll
check the message boards in all the
different countries did I check the
conservative liberal then the
independent moves for different
countries I need multiple different
sources to validate what I might believe
to be true because one is just going to
give you that narrative and that might
not even exist so you said fifth
generational Warfare so you're saying
it's like uh like what does that mean
psychological warfare there are
intelligence agencies that work with
influencers without a doubt
I know I know there's at least three of
them that work with an intelligence
agency and you can't you can't name the
agencies or the influencers oh yeah ncia
mosad and Dia okay because I've heard
the CIA I don't know what the other two
are yeah most odd they're the Israeli
intelligence agencies and defense
intelligence agency uh is the DIA Dia
it's almost a spot well not almost they
have equal powers to see General Michael
Flynn actually was running the DIA prior
to president Trump's presidency
but we have the ACI
and lots and they basically just like
give money to influencers to like push
their agenda multiple ways to control
but it can be money it could be best
ways to compromisation you can get
someone compromised
he got an influencer for life
uh there's some there's some people I've
worked with intelligent agencies that
had a whole different lifestyle and
people wouldn't even believe that the
most respectable people they might have
done something that the audience might
consider the meaning but maybe like uh
uh porn scenes and things like that and
people wouldn't believe in
unintelligence ain't she would set that
up and get the film recorded just to
keep people compromised it goes a lot
deeper I feel as far as to say God if
they if they find out people have the
impact that's that's that's that's
pushing outside the world you will get a
phone call one day of one intelligence
agency let you know either how valuable
you are or how you've already messed up
in your own what's she the one in two so
I think anyone do 20 years in this and
won't press shoulders with any type of
intelligence at this point in fifth
generation Warfare so essentially what
they'll do is they'll so they'll either
get information on somebody or they'll
pay them to like so like the vaccine
would be an example you had all the
influencers pushing the vaccine yeah
and most of that that's like I said
that's mainly intelligence because we
could see without conspiracy that CIA in
Hollywood itself their Creations are
very similar and that Hollywood and CIA
have been integrated since day one it
makes you go to think if the FBI and the
CIA enemy of the people why are they
constantly promoted in Hollywood to make
them look like the cool guys you know we
just see it moving it's like that's the
police that's supposed to do man we have
so many different agencies you know
other than the FBI CIA but it gets so
much promotion so much promotion that
way when you see them and they make any
type of jurisdiction or any type of
judgment it's like those people got to
be wrong I mean they're the heroes in
the movies they're Heroes everywhere
cdia promotion why don't we have Dia
agents saving the damn movies
I don't know what that is
Intelligence Agency so you've got uh
Denzel Washington who does The Equalizer
with the watch team and you got Will
Smith who did the Gemini man both of
those are Dia agents those only two
movies I can really name where Dia agent
is the main cast how many of them have
FBI CIA is just Limitless and you don't
think the DIA is like I guess
compromised or like they're not pushing
the what so why is the CIA like why do
you see the cias compromised and not the
DIA oh oh man it's uh it's all on
leadership it's the leadership that they
answered to honestly it's the leadership
of the dance too they have different
preferences for presidential uh
leadership outside so like the DIA is
more conservative I'd guess and the CIA
is more liberal you could go up to say
that I feel it what do you mean I could
go yes I want to say that like yeah it's
okay
that's about the most accurate way to
look at it like there's Duality yeah
there's even see an intelligence
agencies there's a quote unquote good
side of that son well yeah and I noticed
in the media like that they keep having
these like they'll kind of push because
like my Lane is more like feminism the
history of feminism more and like I'll
just notice they they kind of push like
the girl bosses and like these CEOs and
I'm like I don't see them any I just see
a lot of [__] bad with money
that's what I see it's intelligence
that's actually like intelligence agency
setting these narratives there's a movie
that I liked a little scene it was
called fights movie itself kind of
boring and [__] but it's called Vice and
it'll show about uh Cheney and it showed
how they were all inside of The White
House prior to the war with Iraq Etc and
they were all in there in this movie it
actually shows that they were planning a
narrative they were deciding how would
they describe the war reaching a new
Peak and it was one of the journalists
that said mushroom huge mushroom clouds
you know weapons of mass destruction and
then they act and I mean I wish everyone
in the moment could go to see the scene
in the movie he'll look it up on YouTube
and they asked him they said well that
sounds good but who's the source this is
a room full of journalists in New York
Times Etc Huffington Post with the
president's George Bush and his uh Vice
President George W Bush vice president
and they simply said well which one of
you guys want to be the anonymous source
and all it took was for one journalist
of racism and it's okay to boom that's
not anonymous course the story was
pushed out everywhere through
syndication and that's the type of stuff
that made people say the world is a
stage there are people who actually the
parent intelligence information in the
white house before they pushed out to
the people no one is false but you can
push it if you say I got a allegation
whistleblower these terms prevent people
from having any responsibility or
accountability behind the journalism
that they're pushing out and it's
disgusting because those terms can save
you from anything Wilson blower told me
allegations they live by these things
anonymous source The Source can be one
of their own workers as long as he
choose not to disclose his information
he is anonymous and so you're the
foundation of words okay so you're
saying for the you said the
weaponization of words so when I think
of that I think about how feminism uses
that in the legal system so what they'll
do is like they'll change the definition
and expand it so like um at least with
the Tate stuff
um I I don't they expanded like the
definition of human trafficking so like
human trafficking today is different
than it like would have meant like a
hundred years ago and so then they sort
of like Get guys under things that like
initially wouldn't have been like people
that initially wouldn't have been uh
prosecuted for it well like um I'll give
you an example I think they used um so I
when I think of uh rape it used to be
the the definition of rape used to be
forced sex and it wasn't sex it was like
forced carnal something basically and
they switched it to sex without consent
and consent is subjective so it like
expands the definition so you can like
you know so when when you're saying they
use the weaponization of words
um or the feminist would like add words
so they'd add in like sexual assault
that's really broad right or um so
they'd either change the definition and
expand it or they would add words
um like coercive control Financial abuse
like all these words that don't mean
anything so when I hear this it sounds
kind of similar so they have like
whistleblower they have Anonymous like
they add all these like Words basically
to ex like basically so they don't have
to explain it in a way correct it's
similar to the Haley Bonnet to Ashley
bottom diary Ashley Bottom Dollar was
found and the mainstream media and FBI
they like this they they called the FBI
said the FBF I'm diary Diary sales
inconceivable or something like that
looked at the definition I got to see
the definition of word simply means that
what they did was wrong like it was no
moral it had a low moral uh decision a
low moral active decision but it never
called an inaccurate never called it
false they used it definition that most
Americans never seen attention because
they they just could be damned if the
FBI could say well actually body did
sleep with her damn daddy the president
of the United States and he did touch on
her inappropriately in a molester you
know that's the main problem of it they
never called it
inaccurate but they say it was
did they even say intensible I got to
research I got to look up the word again
the FBI completely quoted if you look at
the definition work then it was a low
moral acting choice but it never simply
stated it was fake that's the
weaponization of the word itself because
you if his faith is fake they'll just
debunk something to call it fate there's
no fact Checkers on that thing yet to
say it's fake they'll constantly talk
about the morality of releasing the
black diary we're talking about politics
mobiles don't matter here it's times you
know they got to talk about what's real
what's fake no one don't want to hear
about immorals and politics this is a
dirty game their job as the FBI was to
validate if it was real or not for them
to say it was immoral or it was a a
morally wrong decision it had to be real
so you said like the weapon I think you
said something earlier like the
weaponization of like mind control I
guess
yeah yeah
the fifth generation of warfare is the
Battle of the run okay and so basically
you have the CIA paying all these
influencers and like what or compromise
yeah or compromising them and that's
like the wars through the media almost
yeah it's just an extension of media
celebrities are extension media
celebrities are brand in their product
they're just another another player on
the stage they're walking talking
product that's why for celebrity hit
someone car is not the same that lost
some hit different that's the whole
brand that hit that car it's not just a
person and they're treated like a brand
how dare you say that how dare you think
this way how dare you eat that how dare
you do that hell even with me trying to
get a dog I was like I want to uh get a
pyramid
you know they got mad at you for wanting
a purebred yep yeah yeah yeah because
they say you got to go to the shelter
and adopt and people don't want to hear
this but shelters aren't any good either
they'll [__] kidnap a dog kidnap dogs
and other animals and clean well we got
two weeks to live you kidnap the
[__] of course you know to play
on people emotions it's a cold world out
here nothing's as pretty as it seem they
fill up shelters to play on people's
hearts like it's it's a rabbit hole
itself
and it's like man you're not really
taking care of anyone but yourself the
unfortunate truth when you're getting a
pet because God there's so many that
need help you can't save them all some
of them are actually Clinton shelters
they make them intentionally look a
certain way of dirty them up just take
those photos and have them go viral
they're not stupid once things have
profit behind it the morals behind that
[__] is gone don't matter if it's
animals babies nothing same thing like
freaking you know the CPS once money is
behind it it's over you be on X look how
much influence has changed since Elon
started paying really people start
changing yeah the engagement performance
is a whole different level I know people
always tell me that I don't understand
what it is like
they they tell me I do that all
that um so the thing you have wow
content I'm sure you're like R-rated too
uh but you don't post like uh graphic
stuff but you post stuff that just will
piss people off so much oh yeah yeah
I just think it's my favorite one is any
way I can argue that younger women are
hot or that's my favorite because the
girls just get so mad
and I'll switch it every time I'll be
like 22 year old women 23 year old
I've seen you go viral on black Twitter
and stuff and I like worldwide
might as well just get so much of a
reaction
what is black Twitter oh it's a
different it's Twitter but it ain't
Twitter so the thing about black Twitter
you can't really understand it because
this is a thing about on regular Twitter
you gotta have like hundreds of
thousands of followers of the viral by
black Twitter no maybe people like 12
followers following 8 000 people make
one [__] post and no one follows them
behind it either one post that [__] get
like 50 000 likes 12 million to 20
million uh views nine thousand retweets
and it's like wet in the hell who is
this person person doesn't even exist
they just said something that black
Twitter like they go viral you don't
need followers to go viral on black
Twitter you don't need anything you just
need to post I don't know how to explain
it anyone everyone goes viral on black
Twitter but when it goes viral no other
part of Twitter comes to you no other
part of them like on average I I like
some numbers I see on there it just
completely shatters everyone else oh
really I pissed someone off on black
Twitter I don't even know well you just
posting it'll go viral there don't
necessarily piss them off they'll be
like who is this or they were like why
is she still going well
and so that's so good yeah just the fact
that someone is happy or is still
standing on their same approach he
pisses people off they want people to
[__] and make a transition they want you
to change and be more of what they are
the problem is you end up being
unauthentic if you do if you build your
brand and people know that's who you are
and that's your beliefs as soon as you
start changing up your same haters and
say oh sold out they lost it or they
feel like they want a battle that never
existed yeah it's like people demand get
a change it's just it's actually
unintentional lie your existence gives
them purpose if you don't exist once the
content to be pissed about to get their
likes and comments yeah well sometimes I
feel like it's more like sometimes on
Twitter at least I'm like kind of
bouncing off ideas off of people I'm
like what do you guys like thinking but
they just they get very people are very
serious tweeters yes they are more
emotions are attracted to Twitter yeah
it's very emotional and so you think
people have like switched
um I haven't noticed too much of a
difference what have you noticed right
yes I have so female specifically just
the women strong like Instagram no doubt
Twitter stronger I can't scroll without
seeing ads oh you're oh you're talking
about okay never seen that never seen it
on Twitter I know what I've seen no I
don't I'm not seeing now God I can't go
four or five seconds without bikinis the
Kings the Kings hell even news at this
point you know only famous girls they
always been there they had a platform
they've been on Twitter since day one
but God is a different level I'm talking
about respectable or I don't want to put
that term because your clothes don't
make you respectable non-respectful to
depends on it I mean that's a whole
different conversation but these are
people that generally never posted this
type of content
and it's like dude yeah you look good as
[__] but I'm not trying to focus on that
okay
but can't be focused like I mean it's
like Instagram did you see that Senator
that like posted a bikini picture and
like a Bible verse yeah like that and
yeah one that was twerking I think a
Democrat candidate that was twerking at
a beach I don't know this is why I think
women shouldn't vote I'm like we just
gotta get out of here
I'm like we just whatever industry we go
into we just can't stop taking our
clothes off I'm like lady
was dead but I do know man
America was a lot different before the
voting uh women started voting it was a
lot different
it's just that more choices in the
political scale was made on action and
not works it was more so about what he
did what his father did what his
grandfather did and then you want to
start the voting this oh he's cute I
didn't like the way he said that you
know look the way he holds his kids
hands me and nobody came about none of
that well we care about the job have you
ever read like The anti-suffragettes
like writings uh yeah I study a lot of
history I've read it it's not what a lot
of people might think but I've read it
yeah I mean they like warned us that's
crazy how much science they had uh some
of the stuff in the past well they like
warned us about this stuff like they
warned us what would happen they said it
yeah they predicted a lot of it
but it does make sense that the party of
degeneracy which a lot of people
consider the Democratic party they
depend heavily on women they depend
heavily on women and they don't even try
to Market and get a meal so it's almost
like the Democrat Party truly doesn't
care about change not because they
Market a limit but because they
marketing emotions and our actions that
tells me everything about that party
you're marketing to the group of people
to the gender that cares more about how
you act and not what you do and to me
that's not really good for a nation and
not to eat it just doesn't make sense
you should be marketing to those that's
keeping you accountable for your actions
and actions that you make not my
children truth though would have never
won guessing through those should have
never won he's the greatest mistake in
Canada and it's just apparent it's the
greatest mistake in Canada no doubt he's
the greatest thing he's the greatest
mistake in Canada yeah for leading
history so in my opinion from everything
I researched I've never seen a leader a
European leader is Madison and uh Daddy
he had such love when he first came in
oh women they could do whatever they
could to get around with Justin I mean
they would do anything they could to get
around Justin there was women in America
I'm thinking about moving to Canada just
to vote Trudeau look what the [__] we
got now you know
it's deeper than that man yeah it's man
what about the concept of this man
character what's his plan I don't know I
mean we love attractive stuff I mean
it's easier to talk to Attractive people
but that narrow point of view there are
people that know they're not ugly
they're going to take advantage and yet
again your emotions and you Market it to
the women now he's over here doing all
this day you know standing with pride
Justin Trudeau looks happy as ever
around transgenders Etc it's a foreign
State I can't even recognize Canada it
was once a time where they say oh more
Americans was going to move to Canada in
the same U.S that doesn't even look
feasible or possible at this point
it's crazy there's only like 12 year
change just the old appearance Barack
Obama yet again an individual that was
marketed on appearance for Optics not
really policy than anyone well and it's
so weird I don't know something kind of
happens like as a check because you kind
of go through life everyone just tells
you what you want to hear 24 7. and it's
like once you can like hear the
pandering you like can't unhear it you
know what I mean like they'll use the
same like like the weaponization of
words like they use these words that
like sound nice
and I'm almost like almost to the point
I just get pissed off because I'm like
it's not pandering like I'm so tired of
the simping yeah
it's the same thing like I guess being
black you get tired of just like the
same thing because it just it's like no
both really happens it just keeps people
stagnant yeah so different than a child
you know uh Pander into a woman black or
anyone it's no different than a child
you're going to continue to behavior
this European culture that I see we have
passport Bros that's blown up and it's
not because they don't love their women
it's because the culture of the women is
not to be loved not in America no [__]
no no just not here
in America now some type of way a
narrative has been put that a woman
being submissive is generally a bad
thing just all around the natural way
everyone and that that's crazy to me
just to sell it and
it's unbelievable there are women with
the monster to think a man could date
you in five years is still unspoons so
the man is surprise there's no doubt
about it I don't see it was always even
understood in the Pro in the past that's
why we overcompensated to make a woman
feel special because we are that special
we are the creators of this world so we
overcompensated in the past to make them
feel equal it was never true it is what
it is it was never true but somehow this
illusion yeah and we see destruction
there is danger in believing in fairy
tales just like a child you don't tell a
child Santa is real and 50 years old and
we are in a fairy tale well and they pay
us to basically be I I really think that
if women left the workforce tomorrow I
really think we would be more productive
not less productive I know maybe this is
hypocritical being that I like do
commentary but but I I really just see a
lot of honestly useless job this is just
how I see it but women we go into
education and we ruined education right
so because you know in the what well I
can see what you need uh yeah there was
a transition for male teachers yeah you
know what's funny the all the IQ tests
started dropping when women entered
education and it used to be one man
produce better results than now two
women because there's a teacher and a
teacher's aide
so and then all the women every industry
like pay attention to the industries
they complain about it's all the ones
women run always like healthcare women
um politics is like right it's not run
by women but like they Pander to the
women they can't get elected without the
women so it's like everything yeah then
we added like the HR department start
telling men how to talk it's like yeah
political commentators come into the
space and start suing everybody
[Laughter]
is holy crap yeah that is crazy about it
there were a whole lot of male teachers
man it's messed up somehow we started to
become a feminine role itself and then
steered away from it because they didn't
want to look feminine yeah that's so
unfortunate where men originally taught
the world they were the Great teachers
yeah that's why I think like actually I
actually would argue that men basically
just pay for women to just like pretty
much do nothing at work most of the time
I do jobs I mean but yeah then I was
obviously ever did we go
what so what the damn thing Kamala
Harris she does it does yeah look at
nothing like just start once you see it
you can't ugly Hillary Clinton works
okay I'm not there's exceptions right
but there's exceptions
but they're okay there's exceptions but
but the rule right like I consider
myself a hard worker right I do but I
just look at like I just look at us as a
group and I'm like 85 of us in the
workforce just like kind of do nothing
like we take every girl that's like
worked for me always wants time off
always want like the guys show up every
day on top like and I just think that
the women are just like monetizing
Beauty so they're really just in
Industries where we make money off of
our looks so like you know media
entertainment assistant at like roles
where they're sitting at the front where
the guys are like doing the hard stuff
yeah in his room like you'll see gamer
girls they blow up just because they're
pretty might be straight dog [__] at the
game it doesn't matter something nice to
look at the self culture has gotten so
strong and I think women the main reason
they've gotten less attractive than men
is just because
every man is too accessible there should
be no error where a woman feel like she
can have any man she won't you got
almost everyone but I could have any men
anymore
there's got to start being people set
these boundaries say I don't give a [__]
how you look I care about what you've
done I care about your energy everyone
you sleep with if it permanently changes
the psychology it it forever affects us
has been proven man you gotta hold them
up to that same standard man I'm denied
women and they damn never want to rape
me and it just tells that they can go
the whole [__] life without being
told Lily no about anything
and that leads to a problem that's like
men got to start denying them they got
to say boundaries they got to let them
know that it's not about sex to me what
else do you offer the room gets real
quiet you would be surprised how quiet
the room gets if you say that is that
all you got it gets very very quiet
because she looks at you like damn
that's that should be all you expect
well yeah
yeah one we're kind of all messed up
because we all got on social media like
13 years old that's like as a chick that
that extreme attention it's like that's
the equivalent of a guy getting to sleep
with a bunch of models like at 13. that
would be so damaging to him but we do
like to women so yeah and then once it
starts to go away we just start getting
delusional and [__] on Pearl for
saying that the older you get you're
gonna get uglier the thing is like
searching for everyone we get older we
age there was a point of time but that
was the beauty of it that's what made us
lovely you it's just that error you can
have Beauty in it I don't know the
process itself should be the beauty well
we ate it's relative really on how we
take care of ourselves for the most part
some is genetics but we can do a lot to
help our favorites
yeah well but we just women we just live
in delusion we think we look like our
filters you know I don't know what it is
I think both genders a little bit
because I mean there's a lot can be said
from now
just because then let's be real man
supposed to be so strong and dominant
how did it get so weak to just let well
it is what it is me I'm weak as hell now
so Nature's women men are very weak to
there are women and I can't believe I
can I can understand it like man a week
of [__] they don't earn my respect it
was a time where every man would pretty
much unrespect a woman he knows the
ghost shot down a tree how many men
could really shot down the tree nowadays
it sounds stupid there's some basic [__]
Lumberjack [__] you can't find it can
you chop down a tree yeah
I don't know but there's like it just
you know these are the things what a guy
I'm just saying things that were simple
in the past no I know I know
men when they were young would take a
six-year-old child son chopping that mug
down they'll spend the whole day yeah
yeah it takes hard work son to get the
street out the the lesson on chopping
down the tree it was almost ritual a
tribal thing in the past you take your
child out when you show them how much
can change with dedication the tree
starts off almost like it's an
impossible feat to take there your
strength your dedication your hard work
will get it down you cutting it down you
create the wood Through the Wood you
heat up the house you create the food
the child is able to learn at a very
early age that the father through
dedication homework and nothing else can
provide there was a time where you have
to take your child's child down trees to
go to go fish because there's lessons
that the children are supposed to learn
from the father that it ain't easy but
it's God damn it's so worth it when it's
time to go home it's worth it this is
why I do what we do
so it's more important than just chop it
on the tree this is the population that
you still to you it's gone we've lost
our culture in America well I I think
that the guys are really weak because
they're just getting robbed I think that
the school system kind of discriminates
against men and there's kind of studies
that like go through this where they
like they'll turn off their cameras
during covid and like the women's grades
will go down
because women like women are just nicer
to other women and they don't have a lot
of sympathy to men so it's like it's
nine the school system's like 90 women
and like we're a lot more egalitarian
they switched they switched like all the
IQ tests and the um the school system to
have like questions that women tend to
do better in and a lot of them are
ideological
um so I really think like and I also I
personally this is just my opinion I
think we have all these useless jobs
that men pay for like women are not net
tax losses where they like they spend
more money even though they make less so
it's like who's paying we're really just
robbing men in my opinion the thing is
we also got to see the origins of it
that can't sound true but this actually
initially started because there was once
a time where people would choose where
it kind of was a man's world yeah
overcompensary over compensate so women
can also exist you don't want to just
live in the world by yourself just a man
well you want you still don't want to be
happy and still feel the man there's
nothing like having purpose yeah
imagine the past you know give us 400
500 years before let's be real it could
be too easy to be a woman just because
they didn't have too much purpose yes
over the husband but I'm sure they had a
lot of identity prices you don't have as
many of those are needing prices now
they might falsely believe there's
something they're not but they might not
know what to believe in the past I think
I think you might have went too far
trying to give an equal footing and
ended up making things unfair and
shifted it and leaving it in One
Direction again
it's in a feminine Direction and I don't
think it's random that the whole goddamn
world is pretty much gay now not at
women well yeah because women are well
I'm just thinking if me and you are in a
contract right and I gain everything by
leaving and you lose everything by
leaving like we're you're always going
to be trying to make me happy and I just
think that's the dynamic we have like I
think that the legal structure of like
marriage
um changes the relationship Dynamics
because the women gain everything the
men lose everything you know so I just I
don't know what to think about marriage
I don't really want to uh I just lose
too much I mean God I made like my first
website like eight years old I've been
working since I finally made so at least
close to where I want to be in my life
just in January to give all that away
from someone I say I just pick up out of
McDonald's that [__] is unfair as well
yeah because there's something it's less
than one percent even making a certain
positions in life and you can choose a
99 and she could be a one percenter just
like that like that is unbelievable that
is breaking the simulation
well I mean that's why guys used to
marry chicks after like three months now
it takes them like I think three four
years on average
the guys are like no no no no no no it
takes three years for me yep you're
right yeah that's the average years
that's my thing and it's like I'm 29 and
like you don't think you're getting
older you [__] less I'd rather die happy
and alone I'll wait my three years yep
I'll wait yeah because it is a long time
I'm surrounded by so many miserable
marriages so many of my friends and
family they're miserable I'm sure your
dog's the same they can lie to me in it
you can hear it when they lie to
yourself they're magical very miserable
it's depression it's like dang I love
both of these people I know you're not
improve each other it's a cold heart
truth hell 80 of people that way I
refuse
be hard on yourself
demand better you know don't settle for
less guidelines then you bring kids into
that situation it's a very depressing
thing
just thinking about I
let us live in delusion illusion so much
that we have single mothers wearing
white on their wedding days I'm like she
got a whole kid why is she and why I was
like the men have been letting us live
in delusion for too long black community
it started a lot in the black community
the whole Pro female I say that strong
pro-female thing starting black
community a little bit harder just
because I don't need no man I Don't Need
No Man the welfare state I don't need my
baby daddy like all that yep and now we
see these young men are lost these
[__] robbing each other these [__]
killing each other a lot of them don't
believe in rap we're doing the most
ignorant [__] because our mother figures
our mother figures are failing us our
mother figures are thinking they're a
father and they're trying to teach us
things only a man can
and now you got emotional men thinking
of being emotionalist gangster [__]
what you said about me you get a gun he
shoot a man in her face you ain't
Gangsta even you're a female bro that
man words got you to kill him that
instant that's a feminine energy that's
not dominant energy dominant Energy is
known you a better man and you walk away
if you try you you lay his ass out
you know no Kings you have to announce
that he's King but if a peasant steps up
you remind him why you wear the crown
but there's no need for Kings to go down
to Peasant land and prove himself that's
what we have man doing now through all
this feminine energy you could have men
that have everything in the world and
they lose it all if a homeless man say
the wrong thing you're a [__] you're
not a man there's no reason these things
should really affect you not the way it
should that's feminine uh to be that
emotional emotion itself is a feminine
trait emotion when you look at
spirituality emotion itself is
considered penny
so the act of emotion if a man shows any
type of trait of emotion he's accessing
his minimum Assad
even anger that's accessing people I
think when it's love and being uh cheesy
you actually feel no damn pissed off is
accessing your feminine side because
females are emotional men are close to
work we're not positive things yeah well
and it's interesting because we're
almost like paying women to be men with
all these like quotas and we're like and
same with um the same like paying women
to be single mothers like through
alimony divorce laws child support and
so it's like you're almost like paying
the women to be the men I think so they
can control the family yeah
and I think to control the family but to
create a slippery slope of destroying
the family structure to make people more
dependent if the family structure is
destroyed if they don't have the goddess
in the home they're going to have to get
it from somewhere else and that comes
from government
um creates a stronger dependency on
government if you can't depend on the
significant other or your father or your
mother
someone has to be your parent that's
what a government steps in and say I'll
be Daddy
right
government put them in that position
it's like a movie it was always set for
you to be there to come back home to the
government yeah when we come out we got
to get that birth certificate it's
almost a promise to the government you
gonna come see me
that birth certificate
Chase I promise that you're going to be
coming to see me one way or the other
that you what
when I got out when we got a baby and we
got our birth certificate signed it's a
promise from the government that we're
going to be seeing them again we're
going to be standing when we first come
into the world
we've introduced to the government with
a birth certificate social security and
things like that that person is a
promise that we are asset to the
government and it's going to get its pay
out of us one way or the
either through the prison school to
prison pipeline being an employee
through taxes Etc that government it
wants to see in the future and it's
going to make do on that check and most
of the time it will do whatever it can
from that moment when you come out of
your mother's womb to separate you from
those two people in that same room they
want to bring you closer to that birth
certificate than their parents in that
room so who do you think so you think
the Democrat Party is behind this
yeah without a doubt and I'm not just
camera to the audience yeah without a
doubt okay tell me why
they've been behind every destruction I
had suffrage and all those things as
Democrat all of the problems that we
have every single problem look at the
homosexuality the homosexuality yeah the
first we started and that started
through the Democratic party yeah at
first we started through feminism
everything is a trend so you start with
the feminism
you start with that then you transition
to homosexuality and then possibly
pedophilia we should bestiality
everything is on the table because it
starts with something that start over
the Democrat Party The Party of emotion
and marketing and women first had to
Market with women and women were way
more acceptance homosexuality simply
because oh it's hot when two women make
out my my family never understood this
about me believe it or not I say oh I
don't think it's cool I don't I don't
get turned on for 200. like like making
up I'm the only man I've ever met that
ever said it every other person said oh
you crazy I've had women I said I'm not
into that that's not not to two women
because I feel like this if it's wrong
for two men
is wrong with two men is wrong with two
women it's wrong with you man if that's
anyone's opinion that's just a bias like
most conservatives I'll say oh I don't
like homosexuality they really just
thinking about gay men
and say oh Jesus this and that they're
talking about two men and really that's
unfair
both should be wrong both should be held
to the same accountability but just like
you said you're telling them what they
want to hear the anti-game movement is
truly just anti-man yet again
well even the trans stuff I thought it
was so interesting how they always are
talking about the men going into the
women's sports but it's 80 female like
um but I mean biological female and then
they also never talked about how the
women go into the men's spaces so like
women used to be banned from Bars were
like there's all these like male spaces
that women weren't allowed in but men
can't have them anymore yeah yeah that's
that's insane yeah the the only showing
one part of it and they only get mad
about certain things people don't even
notice it even when they act like they
met about women they still didn't stop
on a wrist yeah sometimes I think they
should get rid of women's sports and
this is a former athlete telling you
this that's more extreme yeah well okay
okay I I bounced this idea I don't I
don't want to say this isn't like say
you don't do a sports I mean I'm trying
to figure out what did he okay okay okay
so I had this thought this is why I
think we have useless jobs it's the same
reason women's sports operates at a loss
if you look at the college level if you
look at at overseas it's all we're
always losing money
um so and I thought about this
um they basically take the money from
the man the guys at the top take the
money from the men and give it to the
women I think this kind of sounds
familiar with women in the workforce I
think men are taking a pay cut to do
women's jobs my opinion okay and you
know I'm thinking like if the demand was
really there for women's sports wouldn't
we like make money and then I found out
that actually like women's sports
um it actually changes your hormones and
it makes you a lot more masculine so
that's why you see all these like
lesbians in the NBA and the WNBA and
really and I was thinking about like
because basically from the time I was 12
I like traveled to different
um
uh States like twice a month
um I would spend like I would do
basketball and volleyball so I'd spend
like five hours a day in the gym and it
really almost is like a way to replace
the family to be honest because you're
like so much like with the team and it's
run by a bunch of lesbians if I'm being
honest so I I'm a little torn but it's
like if it makes no money and it kind of
makes us like uncontributing to society
do we really need it like it makes us
more you know we basically all waste our
20s just like chasing contracts that
make no money I've seen chicks do it
over and over again
it's common I almost would think
everyone's chasing them the more you
speak it's almost like everyone's
chasing the ghosts that's been put in
front of us
it's uh chasing a false reality I think
everyone is because somehow men they
chase this reality that once they get a
certain amount of money
that all these things just come flooded
to them we get all these women get all
these opportunities or get just this
amount of Happiness to feel like the men
Until you realize like oh wow um that's
only one aspect of who I am the best
thing about a man with money is
is confidence that's about it other than
that it does [__] us wrong the
confidence go up and that's what
attracted to women is a confident man
that you know knows what he wants and
able to attain it but those men are
still chasing a dream of power or
masculinity they attribute money and
success is masculinity that's crazy
being poor or being be important
unsuccessful shouldn't make you any less
masculine in my opinion but
it's almost at the point now modern
society you can't be poor and be
considered masculine nope you got to
have certain type of welfare aspect or a
certain type of person you considered
dominant it shouldn't always have to
deal with the money
everyone's chasing the ghost most men
don't even chase the money for their own
dreams they take some money for their
own identity
they're chasing money for their own
identity what do you mean by that some
men don't have about them I mean they'll
just constantly told what it is like to
be another some men just they'll want
men don't want to be told no
so much they turned out so much they
think having money automatically create
a yes reality where you get everything
you want right you based off money
because almost every single time a girl
has a problem that you're talking to
it's about the money or if you ever
think your girl is cheating first thing
comes from their mind it's weird when
men and women women think oh does she
look better
um that she cook better and all these
other things we just think down to see
him
and just he [__] rep there's only two
things we're very simple
and those things are detrimental to us
very detrimental because we based our
whole entire life of them of
how much can he provide versus me
and that's racing a ghost your entire
identity shouldn't be off of your
ability to provide for someone else but
should be for yourself in my opinion
well and women mate select for looks
first now I got more options now I mean
you don't have to talk to the 80 year
old sugar daddy you got younger people
you know they got more options now it's
a lot better to be a woman outside in
terms of options there was once a time
passed you had to talk to a 60 year old
way more options now
so you had you had a tweet
um call that says
who did Epstein work for so who did he
work for I was a thread it's no way to
confirm but uh Miss Roth show there's a
great chance it would have been this
Lindy Forster Rochelle the uh female
there's a great chance he was working
with her
and be vaticated as a whole okay what
what made you like say that
just the research I did the whole thread
on it the research that I found his
ports that he had for his plane it was
held at Mrs Rothschild's brother and he
constantly visited her Miss Rothschild
had her again almost every last one in
his business all the way down she
connected him with
on his best friends Bill Gates it was
Steve Miss Rothschild was the one who
made that connection uh for them in fact
the same year Mr Rothschild made a
connection with Jeffrey Epstein and Bill
Clinton Jeffy Epstein redesigned the
White House for Bill and Hillary in 1996
I think it was six
four months after he redesigned the
White House Jeffrey Epstein currently
has some sexual abuse charges that were
pending they got wiped away just four
months after the investment that was
done through lending Forester boss child
just herself though even his
infiltration into the science Industry
had links to Lindy Forrester wife's
child and Bart it's a a pretty slippery
slope but it does lead extensively back
to the Rothschild she's enlisted in his
black book more than almost any other
reputable name too so
you basically think that these got like
these rich like powerful people are like
do you think they're like funding the
Democratic party mostly too there's
proofs of it yeah yeah organizations
with their names on them yeah ciao fun
you know they are fun though yeah they
have funds their own family funds and
it's pretty easy to find work and then
there and then we're basically in a
Warfare because they're funding I forgot
you called it
to uh forgot you had the name earlier
but it was um like the fourth generation
like Warfare generation yeah fifth
generational psychological warfare
that's like funded by all these families
and then what they're doing is they're
using like influencers by either
compromising them or or what
to create a stage like you're not even
saying the world's a stage yeah it's
just a state or something yeah
it makes it look so real but it's all
very very fake okay and the only way
that you kind of sift through it is you
have to find like multiple sources in
different like countries
yeah yeah multiple countries helped me
out a lot I've used in different
countries multiple different search
engines and searching by date
specifically through different years
searching by dates what do you mean
you can get certain search uh search
consoles that you can use and you can
search something let's say if I want to
search all information on Jeffrey
Epstein in 1996. I can do that and set
the date filter to only certain things
from 1996 to 1996.
that creates a substantial change
because you can find all the results
that might have not been censored you
know because it's old most of my
information I'm searching for the 90s
that's before the internet
had the systems that they have now to
take a lot of things away if you can
keep your internet browser in the 90s
you can find a lot of information before
it was as relevant as it is
wow I'm gonna try that that's so
interesting yeah I have in terms of
finding information man I think you
could ask my friend Malachi it's about
12 different
12 different uh strategies I do to
provide information so I tell people I'm
living this content y'all I got
Limitless Limitless Limitless content I
could go forever
I never sit there and think
what could I post
I just get information overload on which
one I should I have a lot of information
and data and get more each day why do
you um you had another thread that said
Republicans are evil and racist
yep that was a bait and switch yeah I
know can you can you talk about that
thread
that one right there I think it was just
showing about the Democrat Party and how
the Republican Party pretty much started
off the fight against the Democrat
parties racism Republican party went and
assisted without commenting slavery
itself
Democrat Party existed and was
supposedly built this party on the
slavery platform because of how
profitable it was majority of the nation
was depending on it it wasn't until the
Republicans came up and they chose to
fight against the Democratic party
political party wouldn't even existed it
was starting in the school I thought the
school was it
that's right the wheelchair I got to
remember where but the school it was
actually started in a local school that
used to be a church and a Republican
party legitimately started to be
anti-slavery to try to fight human
rights and to argue that slaves were
limited and without slavery the
Republican Party wouldn't even exist
so when they say it's the 40th slavery
it actually is the Republican party is a
party of slavery but it's a party to end
it
slavery wouldn't exist I mean Republican
party money is this without slavery and
it makes you think like damn Democrats
was that well basically the Democrats
was their first deal
it's always been them it's always been
up from day one it's always been the
and uh that threat concert shows it that
everything that we said as Republicans
even racists it's more more or less can
be said about Democrats yeah well
because they always would say that the
parties switched but they don't really
have the evidence to back it up
yeah their party's never supposed to
know there's no evidence to back it up
out of the whole switch there's only
been a total I think I had listed six in
total six in total Republicans to have a
transition to Democrat ever since the
switch law started in 1950s
that's six people
that's six politicians that's which
that's not enough
it's not enough I mean can they name the
political parties name the president and
switch from Republican and Democrat
Democratic Republican that year when it
happened I want to know and see when
their letters change you know whichever
year the party switched showed me the
Republican president that became a
Democrat show me the Democrat president
that became Republican so much like this
show me all the governors show me all
the city the council
show me all the judges
change their votes for the next
elections
yeah but I don't know why like Democrats
are so good at just like spinning a
narrative and it's so crazy because I've
um I've done so many shows that like
it's kind of weird you start to meet
people and they're like the same
that you can just tell that they've all
seen like the same propaganda and mine's
more about like cultural stuff but it's
just it's so crazy how well like
liberals can just like put propaganda
like in the media to the point that the
general public believes it yeah it's a
lot easier for them too when they
control the General Media yeah so it's
like you control them narrative when you
okay
I mean they just want everything I don't
know I don't even know how to say it in
a nice way these things have everything
I'm serious they got the internet [__]
you got Hollywood they got medicine they
got the education system they can do
what the hell they want yeah they are
they on the medical assistant oh I guess
with covid yes it got a big four male
yeah a big form of substance and perhaps
oh yes yeah yeah a big farmer because it
donates to me I don't why don't
Republicans own anything like why can't
we do the same thing that was once a
time we did in the 90s let's say that we
just lost it all man how like what did
we what did we own in the 90s yeah
Hollywood should we even had Hollywood
people we had Hollywood yes Hollywood
had to be straight from servers in the
past for you sing Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air are you know good times or any
of these old black shows these are black
shows right yeah focused on family
Dynamics about fatherhood single fathers
single mothers gang banging drugs in the
house all these things they were
speaking out against it and most
importantly before they ever ate they
had to say grace in every TV show and
movie in the past it was nothing to see
a family at the table praying in the 90s
that was because conservative right it
was called the religious right they had
a stronghold on the media it wasn't
until Generation X which is a Democrat
extremist group started controlling the
media's narrative this is actually true
and this happened in the 90s but we had
this idea online so how did we at
Council culture we counseled Harry
Potter we canceled hip-hop we canceled
rock and roll you can't do that without
power conservatives started Council
culture so so how did we lose it then
by introducing Council goger once a
society introduces a culture to council
another one it creates a victimhood in
that other Society in the support begins
to grow
because everyone loves the underdog
everyone loves the victim we're
counseling people to be gay of any kind
cancer of homosexuality like you
couldn't even see that gay stuff on TVs
in the past gonna see them movies
because it was all conservative you had
to pray in television hey if you ever
show gangbang and they had to speak of
the importance of not gaining
so I come back in the house leave those
friends it was corny but it was
Christian everything was corny dare to
say no to drugs all that it was a
Christian
conservative stronghold
and they started to push it down people
thought so much that people wanted
freedom because they started feeling
restricted in their own culture we
started feeling restricted I Want to Be
Free that's where pride comes from be
proud to be bold to break out from the
old way of thinking
it was a very restrictive America we
were more accessible but we were very
very restricted the content that was put
on television was different it had
motivations to drive people to love
their families
and it was a conservative minded media
so if um
so if conservatives own the media in the
90s and they basically push the cons
like the religious values almost so much
so that people wanted Freedom yes like
why so did they just lose all their
money is that what happened not they
lose all the supporters the funders the
businesses everyone stopped supporting
them because they said you're not
profitable too many people are fighting
out against you they don't really the
companies don't really
careful
oh but that goes back to when did women
get credit cards and like bank accounts
no but we do see now yet again main
businesses are doing that same
transition yeah pride month this was the
shortest problem we've ever seen there
were companies that took the [__] down
by the fourth that's crazy it was time
to push that down your throat for two
months problem if they were taking those
logos down and stuff by the fourth it's
coming it's coming it's coming not it's
like we just got rid of price out of
Christmas they made it no it's London we
had a whole lot there are flags
everywhere I don't know what I don't
know why maybe it's yourself
yeah it's definitely coming there's no
denying it it came before and As Above
So Below nothing new Under The Sun It's
going to be yeah there's enough to do
this is just a transition we create a
council culture I'll never forget Grand
Theft Auto came out baby whatever they
could have tried to cancel some
Christians and they had the numbers
Harry Potter was not able to be shown to
some movies Harry Potter was not able to
have big books in some libraries because
of America's culture oh it's witchcraft
they putting this witchcraft on our
children take this down that JK Rowling
went through hell but now we see yet the
same conservatives that try to bring JK
Rowling are standing up for her because
she's against transgenderous yeah life
is amazing when you really think about
it and we are reaching another
transition of council culture the same
people that tried to council JK Rowan
are now canceling people that JK Rowling
also believes in councilman it is
nothing new that is here nothing is
truly authentic it's just temporary it's
trendy and soon the trend will be as we
see now to be quote unquote based
anti-democrat and it's going to go so
far until five eight years in the future
we will start canceling it is nothing no
understanding it's going to happen no
matter anything you can do to change it
it's going to happen because it is the
design that way it's not everyone to
decide there will always be these
transitions
this history will repeat so you we when
you say we will start canceling you mean
Republicans well yeah without a doubt
yeah they are doing it now look what
they did about a lot I just wonder if
I I don't know if I maybe you're
probably right you know you you study
these Trends
um at least politically more than I do
but
I don't know the I don't know if I see
it going back until there's policy
changes
um because I just think women we have so
much power right now that I I don't know
how why corporations would like switch
you know when women are most of the
consumer like they make most of the
consumer buying decisions that's easy to
answer simply because it didn't start
through policy it started to repeat
through emotion through the man through
outcrop that passport bro is becoming
more and more problem it's going to be a
problem with our population there will
be policies made
on the back end to affect these things
it's all about the general public when
people stop playing along it's time to
change the name so you're saying too
many guys are gonna like walk away from
yes
walk away from the policy identity and
they'll change it to reflect the people
it makes it like they care this is a
thing
politics are so fake they will make
these changes for the people at the
majority of the world spoke out against
it politicians we elect these people to
make these choices because they post to
know the problems before we do but they
don't change [__] until we have a
massive outcry over a problem so we are
really electing people electing people
to solve things
when it comes in front of them
when we actually initially elected them
to find [__] before it comes in front of
us
there's a huge problem they wait on us
to scream and cry about it and then they
make the changes
yeah it'll be a change because the vast
majority are being conservative they're
going to make the policy change but a
policy change start with the people
demanding it unfortunate and there are
more people than many policy
do you think Trump's going to win the
next election
yes
yeah you don't think those that well I
mean
I I don't even I haven't even I think
they stole it but I just think that
because
um
I just feel like I went to bed and I
woke up and it was switched and I'm like
this has never happened to me in my life
I I don't
like I'm not I'm not going to pretend I
know the ins and outs of it but it just
it seems weird to me
um what I don't know for the fact they
did without a shadow they stole the
election I'll tell anyone I mean they
they simply claimed that in the 2000
election and they claimed it in a 2016
election
there was no problem there there was no
problem it would make it even more
interesting Maxine Waters stood at the
house floor on both interactions and
stated that the election was stolen and
she did not certify the election and
called for the rest of Congress to do so
problem being you need a senator to also
decline to certify the election both
both of those elections Democrats had
zero Senator zero to uh refuse to
certified problem being with 2020
election yes Senate and Congress
approving to the certify the election
something Democrats yet to have then
January 6 just happens not an election
doesn't get an election gets certified
[__] it is what it is it's not fair
they're able to do it but only having
Congress we had a house I mean we had
the Congress uh Congressional house and
we also had the Senate and we weren't
able to even hear our cries because they
went ahead and certified and said well
j6 happened let's go ahead and get this
over with and get a piece from
transition it was BS we had to
justifiable reason to say it was stolen
but we have Justified with people
verifiable people also saying the same
thing have yet to ever have Republican
Arena sorry to have Senate and the house
Congressman members to reject the
election but it happened in 2020 that
part is always often overlooked always
often overlooked because of Jason's but
wouldn't they just do it again no
everything is on narratives everything
is on the world being a state if it was
that easy for them to do it the first
time j6 when it happens you can't have
another j6 got to play a different now
kind of try to kill his character even
more he'll even locking the man up ain't
gonna do it now it's just a new strategy
they're not going to do the same thing
twice well until about 24 years from now
you know
they gotta wait to everyone I forgot
about it but yeah um they don't do it
that quick that's just not their
strategy no I've heard that um from I
guess more of like the conspiracy theory
people which that they basically like
use like they redo things every like 25
to like 50 years yeah
that's why I said we're going to the
transition from a religious right uh
generation next religious right because
they've been in politics the whole time
you just don't even know it they just
wait for their turn it's the world is a
stage they get a 20 and another one get
a 20. we're all just we're all just
playing this game man be honest the
world is so you when you say the world
is a stage you mean like the people
behind the scenes like no this is all
gonna happen and it's just like they're
kind of like playing pretend but they
they know what's happening uh creating
these fossil realities oh yeah even
history yourself can be fake yeah the
photos that you know of Abraham Lincoln
the photos of women church you can look
that up and verify really
history that God damn much holy [__]
what what happened to Foxy right
even like the women's studies
departments are so full of [__] yeah
yeah they're like I wanna I was actually
thinking of enrolling myself as a woman
study student oh God I think I would do
really well
you imagine like me in class you would
uh oh man your professional would
definitely would definitely remember you
forever
um
yeah okay
um well thank you for coming on I feel
like I learned a lot this interview I
think was man you're you're really cool
I really like the energy man thank you
thank you I'm trying to I want to like
be with it with the conspiracy theories
and I felt like you were a good place oh
my gosh before the Suns I have one
question okay this is I've been wanting
to ask why does everyone think Michelle
Obama is a guy
can you please explain so the reason
being
Michelle Obama to me all the information
I have is a woman I've said plenty of
times on Spaces he's a woman reason I'm
saying that because I spoke to someone
that supposedly claimed they slept with
her in high school don't know if you're
true or not but said she was a woman
whatever
it's over the kids man there's a lot of
data of those kids just not being hers
and uh
hell Obama said work Mike couple of
times uh Obama's pretty much [__] gay
I'm sorry it is what it is Obama's a gay
man and uh
it's crazy to be able to even say that
out loud no that's why but Obama's gay
as hell and uh you got Michelle if
well I met so many coincidences that led
people to that point it's like you can't
you can't blame people I mean [__] you
saw the picture I posted with Michelle
Obama hits okay all right all right all
right I am a tall I'm six foot I'm an
athlete so I got big feet too you know
what I mean like I went like Michelle I
promise you no I got pretty I'm Not
Looking I got you see my I got that I
feel better
a compilation
the back strongest [__] okay no no okay
okay because they it kind of happens
when you do sport I don't know if she's
an athlete I was thinking like
so hold on what like so that's strong
you're back all right I mean maybe not
as strong as her she's pretty jacked you
know maybe she's a little more where it
comes from hey I'm not the one calling
her a man I'm just saying
she don't make it easy hey Michelle you
don't make it easy I just I played I
played basketball you know like I was so
I see I've seen a lot of chicks that
look like dudes you know I'm like
yeah she does okay I might believe that
one all right
okay hear me out hear me out hear me out
okay because because
I know chicks that are that tall side
like what is she six seven I don't know
the full height of Britain but it's
she's pretty tall young all right so I
in high school I played with some chicks
that were like
six five because I was on a pretty like
we were like ranked like in the high
school or whatever and um yeah there she
was just all the girls I know that tall
were a lot more Awkward like I just I
could maybe believe and she kinda
I know I'm like flip-flopping I'm a
woman
wrong very masculine I just I'm so tired
of seeing that video of Brittany at the
pool looking
and shaking her head up and down and
then doing a shot at the pool I'm so
tired of seeing that [__] video have
you seen it you know what I'm talking
about there's this one clip of Brittany
grinder at a pool and shoot a ball a
basketball inside the pool a pool of
water it's a basketball attached to the
pool it's the most shared video of her
and you're like you mean this person
this definitely should be a man it's
written without a shirt on it's like you
can get your breasts removed right
but [__] wait this [__] has removed
breasts yes pictures of Britney without
the shirt yes oh what okay she has a
man's chest yeah she has a male chest
like straight up male chest and that's
why people keep saying that I was like
you keep doing well all right well if
she doesn't have boobs you don't think
she's a dude why not she's in the WNBA
why would she why would she remove her
boobs
she is the uh I don't know I don't know
how gay couples work but I think she's
the man or whatever I don't know how to
do anything I think she's the man
version hey look at this is why I say I
you know I'm a little torn because I
really did enjoy the sports I played but
I'm like I really thought about this I'm
like I played this for 16 years what
skill do I really have like I spend
hundreds of hours on this and now it's
like a a kind of useless like I don't
know it's a lot to do with cognition
without a doubt it definitely hope your
cognition and your problem solving
there's no doubt at all maybe I'm not
I'm a smart chick I guess you know with
the basketball what what it's a very
long way though
maybe I don't know but I this is why I
toy with the idea because I just think
if these feminists keep whining about
the pay I would just cut it [__] like
if you guys are gonna keep complaining
like I would if I was the guys and
they're whining about the pay I would
just say okay fine go home it's hard to
be a guy because uh
you got a lot of [__] out here man I
ain't talking about women this man out
here to really try to come shoot another
man for telling a woman what she needs
to be told how dare you say that you're
a woman something ass dude so ain't
never getting like that okay but but
hear me out okay they're born into these
single mother homes that tell them being
a man is bad they go to school where
they're discriminated against and then
they're also told being a man is bad
then they go into the workforce and they
have women HR telling them how to talk
and recruiters that like I've
interviewed recruiters that say men are
discriminated against for high paying
roles so then they go into the workforce
and they're also told being a man is bad
and then all these chicks on the media
or like are telling them how to talk
it's no wonder they come out with like a
chick mind you know I I how are they
supposed to avoid it they haven't
they're they're paid to get rid of
masculinity
there you are and I can I can tell
because when I do shows it's like
there's certain phrases whenever guys
argue the exception that's like a woman
thing so I can that's usually single
mother home when they're like well not
all women are like that or like
not all Democrats what I think my mom
was Hardcore [__] but I was raised with
my father and my mom they were married
helping me married to my mom passed on
that happily married Stay Together the
whole time she was very very hardcore
she just could not stand weak men shave
them so much
uh she just thought they would have
debate a society my mama always would
say if there was a way that she could
just somehow get rid of every weak man
and just snap them away the world be
much better because it creates uh she
said it creates weak women weak men here
we women because they put things in
their head to make them think they're
stronger than they are that's what my
mom was to say say but a strong man will
remind a woman what true strength is and
it's admirable she told me always be a
strong man don't be a man imma take the
strip
yeah
and these symptoms make us delusional
like I'm so tired of these fat chicks
calling themselves tens like yeah and
you know what's so crazy it's so crazy
because if you don't say you're a 10
then all the women are like oh you poor
baby and I'm like what the [__] like a
10 is pretty good like that's like
pretty something that's that's brutal as
you telling a girl that legitly be
considered saying you call her seven
their entire reality shifts it shows how
shallow we are as humans it's like I'm
just one person who cares what I believe
and they'll do whatever they can to
prove to me just that one person that
don't mean anything that they are too
stupid as [__] you got every other man
in the world to say so but
it just showed that man most women have
been given this type of reality where
everything has to go their way if it
doesn't one time
that got their attention they can have a
billion guys one guy say no he's special
enough like that's a shallow mindset we
shouldn't care
who shouldn't care well it's because
we're we're just deluded you know we
just we go through life everyone the
school system's like nicer to us they
give us all these jobs we didn't earn
and we just think we earned them then
like we just monetize Beauty and we like
even even me I'll even say this I think
the guys in the red pill space are a lot
smarter than me you know I think like I
mean like to be honest I I just think as
a chick you don't have to do as much as
a guy especially in media what disagree
you don't do this much I will agree on
that that they don't have to do as much
as fast enough
not not as much no and the main thing is
I think most important part is you see
homelessly on the street
there's people that have poor stuff I
mean just now the rapper Lil Reese was
pouring his his beer from a homeless man
he done that [__] to a woman they kick
his door down if it's homeless woman we
have no loving we don't it's common to
kick the man while I was down actually
it's hilarious to most people they could
come in Wise now but a woman how dare
you that's the point when the whole
world should come together and build her
up lift her up and it's no different
than her parents saving a child every
time you get hard the case is full nasty
toxic individual
did you see the brick lady the lady that
got hit with a brick and was like this
that was good that was good for the
culture
but that was good for the culture for
people to see that you gotta there's the
accountability in my [__] actions in
2023. [__] it is what it is but yeah I
saw it yeah I think more women should
get hit because it's just like I can't I
ain't gonna I ain't gonna get on that I
ain't gonna I don't believe in that
that's just too wild like that's no I do
I think if we like I'm not saying
everyone but I just think like I there's
too many times where I see a chick I
wanted you to do that put Hands On a
Woman we are too strong if you
understand it's different than our
physical uh you know our physical shrimp
it just wouldn't make sense we're
stronger than women I just think that if
we like because we always um
using these guys and it's like I don't
know what you guys expect if if you're
gonna hit a guy what do you think's
gonna happen no no no no no no no no no
no no no
if a guy getting hit he better beat her
ass yeah that's what I'm saying no
problem
yeah no no I'm not saying out of the
blue but I'm saying like for chicks that
are no no yes oh yeah I know I'm an
advocate for that because some of that
[__] can really do damage yeah
oh you thought I just met left and right
no no don't do that
you don't want to let a cat attack them
right because it's dangerous
[__] a woman is too she's a human being
they're very dangerous a human is
dangerous a human is more dangerous than
a cat but people wouldn't let a cat
attack them and they'll let their
girlfriend attack not to [__] me no man
I like my face man I'm sorry you can do
permanent damage with those nails and
[__] and that adrenaline is Flowing I
can't get probably scarred over someone
I wanted to sleep with bro that's not
going to happen to me
I can't afford that
I care too much yeah so well that's
that's why she got hit in the face was
because she was hitting Pete like she's
acting crazy the brick is over
that's I mean man or woman let's be real
that's a damn break I'm sorry that's
just I have to stance on some [__] the
brick is the bad part but I ain't
disapproved with the hit but God damn
you know how hard a brick is seriously
that [__] hurts like a [__] they hit
her in the face with a brick like dude
that could be attempted murder
so I mean I ain't it's good that she got
hit but [__] a goddamn brick I ain't
gonna lie I don't hmm
yeah that that is Extreme a freak man
well
thanks for coming on what up what a fun
day I agree yeah I appreciate it uh
where can where you want to tell the
people where they can find you Instagram
YouTube really not YouTube like that I
don't even post but I have one you
should you should do your YouTube I want
to one day I'll try to get my trying to
be like get my Twitter to a million then
start focusing on YouTube and break out
most people to get to a million on their
main platform and start breaking out so
as soon as I get to a million on Twitter
I'll start pushing YouTube heavily but
Instagram YouTube Facebook
uh are the main places to find me just
search dlm lucre and it should come up
anywhere guys make sure you go follow
him and subscribe to his YouTube we're
gonna get him going on YouTube
um okay um guys make sure you like the
video on your way out and let me know
who you want me to have on next on the
sit down make sure you subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
I'll talk to you next time thank you
it's been a pleasure I hope you guys
with you online